hey I'm Kristian harloff and I'm Tiffany
Smith and our special guest on this
week's episode is comic book writer
fanboy and youtuber Neil McNeil this is
movie 3 song that was like the best one
we've ever had I would I am the best you
will ever have sound whoa that's good
appropriate to the title you tear it up
Neal thank you sir we are awesome thank
you for being part of of movie 3 so
thanks for having me now you're very
popular YouTube channel you talk about
superheroes and comic books and recently
you had an IndieGoGo campaign that you
got funded you tell us a little bit
about that I come up with this idea for
a comic and two months later we decided
to get it Illustrated launch it and we
made twice two hundred percent of our
goal a little bit over that so it's been
a really cool process and it's just all
about finding friends love and also
navigating the world of superheroes so I
know you love superheroes because we
actually got to work together on DC all
access but while we were there I also
found out you're a massive film fan as
well I think the first one that I really
latched on to why the kid was Star Wars
I like him they rereleased all those in
the 90s I got to see them like one after
the other like bang bang bang had no
idea as a kid that those were like
movies from the 70s I thought at the
time I was like wow these new Star Wars
movies are so great i love them and then
they came out with the prequels and I
don't talk about those here I know I'm
just trying to bring it up so we like to
do a little thing called the weekly
wager here on movie threesome we did one
last week for sinister to right and i
believe that you bet 14 million and you
bet 16.5 million Christian now the
estimated box i'll just take this
you're too was ten point six million
which means so this week's loser should
says loser should get slapped with a
fish I don't care when or why I just
want to see someone gets slapped with a
fish Freeman fish know what has fish I
was actually at the Santa Monica Pier
last week so I have some fish in my car
actually this is not what I expected it
to be I take this beat our entire crew
of the fish sorry that you got a part of
the loser should let's just move on to
this week's weekly wagers there's not
time movies opening up this weekend we
just have the zac efron we are your
friends film coming out I'm gonna say
that we are your friends is gonna make
eight million dollars even though I
don't think it's gonna make a lot of
money I'd like to think that neighbors
will at least give them a boost 9.5
million for this thing for you guys to
get involved make sure you use that
hashtag loser should in the YouTube
comments on Twitter on Facebook make
sure it's something awful for Christian
someone should wrestle a bear and our
teams that go lv hysterical christian
loses again let him fight a pair and
then i'm gonna fight it there you smell
so much like fish that a bear would eat
you right through can we get some
tissues and urine smells disgusting
I get these things yes don't throw it at
me today's topic sinister 2 opened up
let's talk a little bit about horror
films I wasn't allowed to watch them
when I was younger when I did see them
they terrified the crap out of me i
watch child's play as a seven-year-old
generally you'll know it's me in a
theater if something scary happens
because I just start saying nope in the
quiet moments I'm like no nope nope
don't go we also say that during
nymphomaniac volume 2 last night I was
rewatching all the scream movies and
random lights in my apartment destructed
flickering on and off I'm never coming
to your apartment by the way I wanted to
ask the fans out there he's there so
many different horror movies out there
night you weren't allowed to watch
horror movies and you watch them at
seven years old how would you introduce
somebody to the horror genre is there a
particular movie comment below and tell
us what you think mine would be psycho
ok horror film class that will scare
anybody sex in the city two I mean it
does still give me nightmares and
there's so many cliches for horror films
where it's like don't go upstairs don't
say I'll be right back are there any
horror films that you can think of where
you're like yep they did it right i
would say aliens grab guns and shoot
until you can't shoot anymore yeah and
that's what you would do what about
oculus I mean she set up an entire
intricate trap to catch this ghost and
in the event that she died she would
destroy the mirror she knew everything
that she had to do to make sure that
this ghost was caught and caught on film
and she still I mean yeah I don't wanna
I don't want to talk about it I'm not
gonna I'm actually really impressed with
the knowledge that you both have a
horror film which leads me to want to
know who actually we on the show we play
a game wait I'm gonna make it
alright so it is game time and the game
for today is to cliché or not too cliche
what I'm gonna do is give you guys a
possible cliche from a war film and you
have to tell me if it is true or false
and you can get a bonus point if you can
tell me if it is a true cliche what film
it happens ready okay zombies that
always walk false because in 28 days
later they run all right there's never
cell phone reception true sorority row
correct the black friend always dies
first scream too true or false true
scream too okay killers are always
what's the phone false that was a
cheater mood I'll give it to him for
losing the car never starts we want it
to that is true scream for I just
watched all the screens I'm sorry that's
our omens of do uh true you still Falls
no it is it Batman it's not an omen md
holding up it is do understand this one
horny librarians yes it is that lady was
horny they just didn't know Bill McNeal
wins too cliche or not too cliche i
would say nice
so you spin it and you either get see
here or do you don't have to poop if you
get the poop okay thank goodness
oh okay so you got to which means you
can do or make us do whatever you want
let's do a seance so how do we even do a
seance I just have to concentrate on the
most evil thing you can imagine
something that you hate that's easy
Kevin get out of here thank you so much
to do before completing our movie Risa
make sure you check it out on social
media Neil underscore McNeil and check
out his YouTube channel Neil MacNeill
and subscribe to this YouTube channel
and make sure you download the fandango
movie clips app on your smart phones and
join us next week on moving Risa what
what what what then I'm gonna fight it
do you want to slap a fish Barry Bonds